leute herzlich willkommen so einem video
von dem ich erst wenn ich das machen
würde
ich habe mein neues auto gekauft
eigentlich bin ich ja jemand der wissen
spaß erlebt aber ich muss sagen weil es
beim autohändler und kälte steht im
moment im leben einfach nicht
widerstehen kann
ja habe ich zugeschlagen aber immerhin
bekommt jetzt heute was zu sehen und
zwar
mein name ist damit die auf
hmm
direkt ist weg aber das okay leute die
machen jetzt mal keine automarke immer
kurz durch was sollte besonders macht ja
also der mit licht und leon motor presse
stuttgart machen ich könnte mir
besonders wichtig beim ort die tür
aufmachen zu können deswegen habe ich
bei diesem auto das hilfspaket für
10.000 euro mitbestellt das beinhaltet
haben wir den reifen mit ihm verbinden
jetzt kommen wir dazu wie es schaffen
könnte dieses auto für zwei euro auf dem
flohmarkt lädt er mich daran irgendein
idiot hatten einfach was drauf
geschrieben
irgendjemand hat hier ja ja queen also
dass ein yak ministers und wir haben
noch was drauf geschrieben so dumm
auf jeden fall leute ich habe ein großes
herz gezeigt haben irgendeinen der passt
auf mich ins auto ich hab's genommen ist
jetzt mein auto was draufsteht ist nicht
sogar aber immerhin
ansonsten hier ja mal auch direkter und
irischen stein
da schöne rose
er hat damit gerechnet aber wir haben
auf der anderen seite auch noch mal 12
felgen
aber das gute ist die karre fährt halt
noch und deswegen drehen eine kleine
runde einig dass die mega war mir drin
hat auch ein eingebautes order pack hat
nur fenster geht nicht als autor david
wie man sieht auch eine eingebaute sauna
sie hat eine halbe milliarde gekostet
ursprünglich habe es einen ganz günstig
bekommt übrigens lukas hier ist der
kameramann dann erste fahrstunde wir
machen mode und erste kontakte könnt ihr
sowieso nicht einmal der fall aus
warum
scheiß was wir von den bauern oben
ein haufen fahren
da vorne mit bisschen frei
eines tages um bringen ich werde mich
auch heute noch umbringen diesem video
herzlich willkommen zum fahrschüler mit
eher sinken
heute in der ersten stunde lernen wir
wie man ihn fertig gemacht
davon ist ein auto
zum breite kommt hinterher dann fahren
wir einfach zum super
die leute jetzt mal ein paar ernste
worte ich persönlich bin mensch der
autos nicht ich gerne mag man vielleicht
gedreht hat jetzt das ziemlich viel spaß
mal gefunden aber ich muss auch sagen
dass der unterschied zwischen dem auto
was ich sicher und wohlbehalten durch
die gegend fährt und was vielleicht 5000
euro kostet und irgend supersportwagen
der vielleicht 100.000 euro kosten
relativ gering ist zumindest was den
benutzten angeht also ihr zahlt quasi
95.000 euro mehr jetzt in diesem
beispiel dafür dass ihr bisschen
schneller durch die gegend fährt
dementsprechend weil ich so denke ist
das natürlich auch nicht mein eigenes
auto ich persönlich fahre ein deutlich
kleineres auto was vom preisbeispiel er
so in richtung der 5.000 euro kommt was
ich einfach sagen möchte es kommt nicht
auf die idee leute das smi nötig ist so
ein dickes auto zu haben um gut zu sein
nur weil keine ahnung welche ablesen das
jetzt machen im tablets sind vielleicht
sogar die leute die böden die so viel
kohle für ein auto ausgeben weil sie ihr
geld nicht beisammen halten können ich
meine es macht spaß und auto auf jeden
fall es macht spaß aber jeder mensch
muss sich quasi selbst fragen macht es
sinn so viel mehr geld auszugeben nur um
schneller durch die gegend zu fahren
macht euch darüber einfach eigenen
gedanken und ich möchte einfach nicht
dass irgendwas leute da draußen glauben
dass es nötig ist irgendwie ein dickes
auto zu haben oder teure markenklamotten
zu tragen und cool zu sein
generell coolness glück alles auf man
quasi im leben braucht eigentlich mal
von innen heraus so das kann niemals
irgendwas material ist wie ein auto oder
an oder man kann derjenige es befriedigt
sind eine coole sache
nice to have aber es ist am anfang geil
aber man gewöhnt sich sehr sehr schnell
dran es ist wirklich so nah listen
schnell das auto auch wie jedes andere
auto wenn ihr die kohle abgibt lieber
der vorauswahl auf urlaub zu machen oder
materiell tag der freude oder spart sie
sich zum beispiel spar extrem vielen
also ich möchte das video hier nutzen
was hingegen punkt zu machen und ich
sage euch gemacht nicht letzterer geld
sinnvoller ein
das war von mir oberen aus